a Maryland woman is taking inspiration
from an oscar-winning movie to try to
solve the decades-old murder mystery of
her twin sister
23 year old college student Jody lecornu
was shot outside Baltimore in 1996 now
her sister hopes billboard ads will help
find the killer
Errol Barnett is at one of the
billboards in Baltimore
Errol good morning good morning look the
busy road behind me is the point you can
see one of three billboards Jenny
kerreri has put up all over town trying
to grab people's attention now she
admits that she's lost time with her
husband and children because she's been
so consumed with her twins case and now
she's willing to put up her inheritance
to pay for a possible break through some
of the pictures I can't even tell us
apart
Jenny kerreri says no one knew her twin
sister Jodi lecornu better than she did
that whole night was very out of
character for her on a snowy March in
1996 lecornu went to a bar with some
friends after a fight with her boyfriend
around 4:00 a.m. she gave someone a ride
home bought more alcohol and made phone
calls from a store parking lot she never
would have done that to sit in a dark
parking lot according to police a
witness at a gas station saw a man in a
white BMW approached lakorn whose car
the two spoke but as lecornu began a
drive away the suspect shot her through
her car's rear passenger window severing
her spine lecornu then somehow drove
across the street when she stopped he
drove up to her car and got out and I
think she had died at that point the
witnesses said he reached over her body
put her car in park and took something
out of it 23 years later with no leads
Carrera is desperate for answers least I
had a data hoping and that's more than
I've had for a while
inspired by the oscar-winning film three
billboards outside Epping Missouri where
you keep a case in the public eye a
better chance they're getting it solved
Carrera is putting up a series of her
own I pitched three different locations
and offering $100,000 to anyone who can
help find her sister's killer right now
we're comfortable saying we don't have
any leads
corporal Shawn Vinson is with the
Baltimore County Police Department no
fingerprints no DNA I don't want to say
what exactly evidence that we have and
what we don't have the family is trying
to put as much pressure as possible on
you guys and on the public to get a
break but we want to be held accountable
any information that we do receive that
we are going to follow up on kerreri
solving her twins murder means finding
peace if there's someone out there who
has some information what would you say
to them oh just please come forward this
is just ripping me apart kerreri also
tells us our family has sued to access
the original autopsy and police report
but they've been unable to view them we
also tried to access those documents but
we're told by the state's attorney's
office it cannot release them because
this is still an active investigation
bianna one thing is clear she won't stop
until she gets justice for her twin
sister Jody and wishing her all the best
Erol thank you